[Musica]
grazie della presentazione favolosa
grazie dell'applauso e per un attimo in
entrare subito in quello che faccio
manderei un video sperando che vada
e poi ci vediamo dopo il video si
[Musica]
all
[Applauso]
bene come è stato detto nella
presentazione io sono tornato da ormai
da un mese dal giappone
dovevo fatto una traversata in un tempio
zen e prima della traversata sono andato
un po in giro a rivedere il giappone a
visitarlo nuovamente e sono tornato foto
al al cimitero di coi a san rocchino
luchino in dove è sepolto il fondatore
della setta buddista shingon e sepolto e
in meditazione in attesa del risveglio e
il punto è che in questo cimitero
la morte è trattata con gentilezza e
mentre ero lì che passeggiava tra le
pietre tra il muschio tra alberi
altissimi mi son venuto in mente due
episodi uno è un episodio che mi fu
raccontato non mi ricordo bene da chi e
non mi ricordo esattamente come ma la
sostanza è questa qua un maestro zen un
illuminato in procinto di morire
ricevette i suoi discepoli 1 gli chiese
se avesse paura e lui rispose sì rispose
che aveva paura
questa risposta questa storia e la sua
risposta mi turbano molto perché io
pensavo che avrei praticato lo zen per
molti anni e sarei morto senza paura il
mio punto era un po questo qua ha detto
un maestro zen un illuminato che
dovrebbe essere un pochino quello che
rappresenta lo zen muore avendo paura o
addirittura pensato che forse aveva
buttato di tutti gli anni di pratica con
questa risposta mi spiazza abbastanza e
non riuscivo bene a inquadrarla poi mi
venne in mente un altro episodio
di quest'estate quando ho fatto uno
stage di apnea profonda con davide
carriera una pista italiano un recordman
un campione del mondo che va a 114 metri
di profondità in questo stage
io gli chiesi questa cosa quasi che
guarda io quando vado sul cavo quando
deve affrontare il mio vuoto
trovo un appoggio trovo un punto dove
appoggiarmi nel respiro la regolarità
del respiro nella ciclicità dell'atto ma
dico tu ovviamente in apnea non si
respirava il g1 non respiri e gli ho
chiesto dove trovarsi lui un appoggiano
dove poteva fare leva lui per affrontare
il suo buio e la sua profondità e lui mi
disse nel mare mi sciolgono elemento
acqua di vento acqua e vado giù trovo un
punto di forza in quello che
apparentemente è un problema cioè la
stessa profondità allo stesso male e poi
mi disse che il mare va trattato con
gentilezza
perché se tu pensi di andar giù a rubare
un metro in più al mare per fare il
record del mondo per mettere una tacca
in più sul tuo orologio dice non va è
molto lontano non è pensabile che un po
discorso che facevo quel vuoto di potere
affrontare il mare il vuoto o la paura
in un rapporto corpo a corpo hanno già
vinto
e allora bisogna essere gentili questa
cosa della gentilezza mia mi ha fatto
riflettere molto e mi sono messo a
pensare per trovare la gentilezza per
vedere come nascesse dove si sviluppasse
a quando invece io non sono gentile a
dove in smetto di essere gentile perchè
finchè va tutto bene finché tutto bello
e comodo è abbastanza facile essere
gentili il punto è quando si smette di
esserlo o meglio si iniziò a essere poco
gentile
e facendo attenzione a questi momenti mi
sono accorto che l'inizio della non
gentilezza per me e nel corpo il corpo
si irrigidisce ci sono degli
irrigidimenti anche piccoli e lo zaino
un pochino mi aiutato essere sensibile
anche alle piccole cose che succedono ma
il corpo si rigidi c'e poi quando si
arriva ad alterare respiro siamo ben
oltre non essere gentili quando salterà
respiro sono piuttosto incazzato è
un'altra roba
però diciamo noi stiamo parlando ancora
un po prima no allora piccole barriere
che si creano nel corpo piccole
resistenze che allontanano che mettono
la persona con cui sono poco gentile
lontano e come ha detto prima è il
jacopo dice fa paura quello che
guardiamo da lontano perché continuiamo
a non conoscerlo e allora se siamo poco
gentili allontaniamo e non conosciamo è
sicuramente se allontaniamo il mare se
non conosciamo se prende le distanze
dalla paura dal vuoto o dal male non
potremmo essere gentili non potremo
fonderci come colmare come mi ha
suggerito davide non potrei diventare
vuoto che invece quello che cerco di
fare quando sono sul cavo è certo che
questo fatto di non mettere barriere di
fondersi con la cosa che ci dà problemi
o comunque il confonderci con quello che
abbiamo di fronte con quello che andiamo
ad affrontare mette paura perché in
qualche modo diventiamo vulnerabili
perdiamo un pochino anche la nostra
identità perché quando davide diventa
mare io divento vuoto smetto un pochino
di essere me stessa
e allora forse anche con questa paura è
il caso di essere gentili quindi prima
di tutto
cerco di essere gentile con me stesso
con le mie paure con la mia rabbia con
tutti gli aspetti che mi fanno anche
arrabbiare di me stesso che comunque in
quel momento vorrei non avere e la paura
è un'altra cosa che lavora molto sul
corpo e quindi se io riesco a essere
gentile con la paura riesco
camminare sul cavo in maniera efficace
perché camminare sul cavo come fare
aprea come arrampicare con un corpo
contratto con un respiro non adeguato
non è funzionale si può fare però non
vai alle profondità di davide non fai
certe attraversate che fortunatamente
sono riuscito a fare quindi collocata la
gentilezza nel corpo nelle condizioni
muscolari e di respiro del corpo
vorrei invitarvi ora fare un piccolo
esercizio che io spesso faccio prima
delle traversate o prima dei test ma noi
in questo caso perché è stato ascoltato
molto volentieri tutto quello che
succedeva prima
e però ecco vi inviterei come sa fare
questo esercizio che richiede prima di
tutto di mettersi seduti comodamente
perché la comodità e la joe sono anche
aspetti importanti del mio lavoro e
penso anche di quello di davide o di chi
non essere a proprio agio anche in
situazioni un pochino critiche e tra
l'altro voi non dovreste essere
istituzioni critiche quindi consiglio di
sciogliere le braccia grazie e mettere
le mani così con i palmi in alto lungo
le gambe ok seduti comodi respiriamo
come stiamo già facendo tranquillamente
e poi vi invito a chiudere gli occhi
continuando a respirare con leggerezza
con normalmente portiamo all'attenzione
alla nostra mano destra
mentre inspiriamo chiudiamo il pugno
mentre ispiriamo lasciamo che la mano si
apra non è un atto di volontà non
vogliamo aprire la mano noi rilasciamo i
muscoli che prima abbiamo contratto e la
mano si apre naturalmente quindi inspiro
chiudo la mano respiro lascia che la
mano si apre
facciamo attenzione a usare proprio i
muscoli esclusivamente quelli necessari
a chiudere la mano quindi non
coinvolgiamo nel movimento il braccio la
spalla scapole collo proprio soli
muscoli dell'avambraccio che sono il
minimo indispensabile per chiudere la
mano dopodiché lasciando uscire l'aria
lasciamo che i muscoli si distendano e
la mano si apre
con il prossimo respiro mentre portiamo
dentro l'aria chiudiamo alla mano con un
pochino più di forza
dopodiché lasciando di nuovo che si apre
col prossimo respiro quando abbiamo alla
mano chiusa ai polmoni pieni
ci fermiamo un attimo lì proprio un
attimo in più di apnea polmoni pieni
dopodiché lasciamo uscire l'aria
lasciamo anche la mano siata quindi
inspiro chiudo la mano tengo il fiato un
pochettino
dopo di che lascio che la mano si apra è
che l'aria resca
con il prossimo respiro quando abbiamo i
polmoni vuoti e la mano aperta
rimaniamo un attimo in più
laggiù in fondo con i polmoni vuoti
inspiro chiudo la mano
sto lascia un attimo a polmoni pieni
mano chiusa dopo di che lascia uscire
l'aria lascio che la mano si apra e
quando i polmoni sono vuoti
sto un attimo la e poi riprendo
naturalmente respirare e riprendo questo
esercizio ancora un po di volte
mentre apro la mano immagino che questa
sensazione di rilassatezza che si
propone nell'avambraccio si diffonda in
tutto il corpo
facciamo ancora tre respiri così
dopodiché quando avete finito di farli
tutti e tre
aprite gli occhi con i vostri tempi così
io vedo che avete finito
se qualcuno non è ancora aperto gli
occhi ora io lo do per addormentato e
vado avanti
allora per me questo esercizio
importante perché in fondo al respiro
quando abbiamo i polmoni vuoti la mano
aperta c'è un punto in cui
tendenzialmente stiamo poco che è anche
definito la piccola morte secondo me un
punto di assenza e di abbandono che può
avere qualche sapore qualche gusto
qualche cosa se non altro un punto nuovo
dove secondo me interessante stare
ed è interessante la mano che si apre
perché una mano che lascia andare quello
che c'è e accoglie quello che sarà e se
noi nell'accogliere quello che sarà
saremo rilassati e avremo respiro
regolare ecco che saremo gentili o forse
è meglio dire saremo aggraziati perché
una situazione del corpo e allora forse
quel maestro zen che stava per morire si
aveva paura ma sia anche aveva la mano
aperta ad accogliere con gentilezza la
sua paura e la sua morte e quindi era
pronto per fare il suo ultimo ultimo per
fare quel suo passaggio con gentilezza e
con grazia
[Applauso]